my brother Robert Baratheon had raised
the banners of Storm's end our ancestral
Castle against the Mad King
arys John Aaron of the veale and edhard
Stark of the north stood with him and
Hoster Tully of the riverlands would
join but their lands were far from ours
and separated by the combined strength
of the West the reach and King's Landing
itself even Robert's own Lords were
against him it was the hardest Choice
I've ever made my brother or my king
blood or
honor a is ruled by right of all the
laws in
westos everyone knew the price of
defiance but there are deeper older
laws the younger brother bows before the
Elder for free you can now listen to the
entire audiobook Fire and Blood On which
house of the Dragon is based and which
covers the entire targaryan history
including current and future events of
House of the Dragon for free with a
notable trial using her Link in the
description I followed
Robert Early in the war ma Terrell's
indecisive victory at Ashford cut Robert
off from Storm's end instead of pursuing
Robert and risking his record M Terell
turned East and laid Siege to our home
his vast Army and Navy encircled us and
prevented any resupply by land or sea if
wagon tried to reach us it was burnt if
a ship tried to land it was sunk we were
locked in Storm's end to starve but
Robert commanded me to hold the castle
no matter the cost he could ill afford
to lose his ancient seat which had never
fallen while Robert smashed rhaegar on
the tridon my men ate the dogs because
the horses had already been
devoured while the Lannisters sacked
King's Landing we ate the rats if The
Smuggler Davos had not slipped through
the Terrell blockade with his onions
we'd have eaten our own
dead but I held the castle until Lord
edhard remembered us and marched to lift
The Siege the Terell didn't even put up
a
fight and Robert threw a feast to
celebrate Lord ard's
Victory I was sent to the Royal Island
stronghold of Dragonstone to deal with
vus and dairis the last surviving tarian
children before I arrived however they
escaped across the narrow sea Robert was
Furious he stripped me of Storm's end
and gave it to that prancing fool renley
my younger
brother Wars are not as good for
Smugglers as you'd think every Harbor
fills with guards and inspectors and the
Seas filled with Blockheads and Pirates
paid by each side to pray on the other
though I had no love for the Mad King
I'd grown up around the power of King's
Landon I figured this Robert Baratheon
would end the same as the other rebel
Lords burnt deash but he didn't the
north the riverlands and the veil joined
him and then the taverns people drank
the Robert's Health openly bra fools I
thought but I had a family who'd be left
in the cold if I lost my head when m
Terell marched on Robert's home of
Storm's end as by the end of the
Rebellion the castle was garrisoned by
Robert's younger brother Stanis and the
small guard and would not hold out for
long when it fell Robert would be
homeless and his support had bleed away
this I knew from
experience months later Stannis was
still holding in the castle nobody cared
but on
voyages I had seen what famine does and
I thought of all those men in Storm's
end who would die unmourned and
forgotten no better than flea bottom
orphans I told my wife and myself that
I'd get a high price for the onions and
salt beef in truth I knew itd be
captured by the Terell GES or drowned
but it was too stubborn later that night
in the dark in a tiny boat with a black
sail I cursed myself and the Moonlight
as I waited for the tide to turn when I
did the wind beat the sail so hard I
ripped it down fearing the Terrell ships
would hear luckily they had grown
LAX with muffled ores alone I steered my
cargo through the treacherous currents
and snars of rock that gave shipbreaker
Bay its
name the waves finally carried me soaked
and near blind from sea water through
the mouth of the cavern beneath the
castle then Stannis barathan AR
arrived The Siege had left him gaunt but
not weak never weak he greeted me and
accepted my onions with cool courtesy
betraying no emotion even as all
wept he dled out the food to his wife
and each of his men before he ate
himself a portion no larger than any
other when he finally thanked me I could
see his mind had already returned to the
Castle's
defense his duty after Aries fell and
Lord Stark lifted The Siege stanna
summoned me for my salvation of Storm's
end I was to be granted a Knighthood a
keep of my own and my son taken into
stannis's personal service Davos of flee
bottom had become sir Davis of house
seaworth and his son would serve the
king's own brother but for my previous
crimes as a Smuggler I was to have the
fingertips of one hand hand taken off
above the highest joint stanus hell that
I had flouted the laws of the land for
years and a good act does not wash out
the bad in one Fell Swoop or five
Stannis gave my son a future and my
family a name that I could never have
imagined nor earned on my own I still
keep the finger bores in a bag around my
neck to remind me what I was and what I
ow a
Stannis for du of my many years as a
Smuggler I visited many ports taverns
and back alleys and saw many things in
this
world but never
Justice until
Stannis
Rebellion the crimes of House Targaryen
were too heinous to go
unanswered the noble houses of barathan
Stark and Aaron United to oppose and
overthrow the line of the cursed dragon
Kings while Ned Stark and Aaron secured
an alliance with the tules of riverrun I
called the banners of Storm's end and
rode out in force against the Mad King
and his minions Gods those were some
battles our first Victory occurred at
summer Hall where I faced off against an
army of dragon Loyalists and won three
battles in a single day three in one day
seven Hells that was a glorious day we
tried to take Ashford castle in the
reach but the trills beat us back we had
to
regroup my Army was pursued North by
eris's Army and took refuge in the Stony
sept in the
riverlands when the targaryan Army
entered the town the sept Bells told a
signal to the town's people of the
battle that was to
come as the targaryan searched from
house to house for me the combined
forces of Ned Stark and the tules swept
into the city Gods what a day that
was it's now known as the battle of the
Bells we overwhelmed the Mad king's
forces and sent them scampering back to
King's
Landing ais's son rhaegar who started
the whole damn thing finally emerged
from hiding in the South and assembled
his own Army to face us as for the Mad
King he must have been pissing
himself the battle that would decide the
fate of the Seven Kingdoms occurred at
the Crossing of the green Fork of the
Trident
River rhaegar commanded the Royal host
which was some 40,000 strong my forces
were outnumbered by nearly 5,000 men but
that didn't
matter they were fresh but we were
battle hardened and had Justice on our
side as the battle raged around us I
faced off with rhaegar the Stag and the
dragon right there in the Ford of the
river I fought with the fury of 10 men
reigning blow after to blow upon that
vile Prince before Burying my Warhammer
in his chest I hit him so hard the
rubies on his armor Broke Free flinging
them into the stream they call it the
Ruby Ford now
with that scum rhaegar dead and the
Royal Army shattered our next move was
to make for King's
Landing but I'd sustained a few wounds
in the battle and was unable to ride I
sent Ned Stark to the capital to face
the Mad King and make him pay for his
crimes the tarians blood of the dragon
and the last of old valyria were loved
by their subjects and admired far and
wide as the greatest Dynasty in the
history of the western world but the
peace and prosperity of nearly three
centuries of targaryan rule was
shattered by the usurper Robert
Baratheon and his band of
traitors house Baratheon owed its very
existence to the
targaryens was it not Aon the dragon
himself who elevated the bastard orus
Baratheon in the war of conquest and
what of the Starks the Lannisters the
erands of the veil all had been spared
and allowed to keep their lands when Aon
could easily have wiped them out
centuries later the usurper and his
Lackey repaid aon's benevolence with
treachery there are some who dare to
claim Robert and his allies had reason
to Rebel they say the Crown Prince stole
the usurper lady love they say my father
King Aries murdered Rickard star
darkened his son without just cause
whether these charges are true or not it
doesn't matter the dragon answers to No
One Aries his good name has been besched
in the years since the Rebellion he's
been called a dangerous madman a monster
a tyrant that brought his tragic end
upon himself
lies my father was a victim of weaklings
in his Council lawitz who failed him in
his hour of need and let the Rebellion
spin out of
control but it was not
enough the Royal Army was crushed at the
Battle of the
Trident it was there the Valiant rhaegar
met Robert in single combat but the gods
betrayed him and he perished by the
usurper
hand as the Field of Fire had marked the
end of the andle centuries
before the battle of the Trident seemed
to Herald the end of the Dragon
Kings when when word reached the capital
of my brother rhaegar's death my father
arys moved to protect me as I was the
surviving heir to the throne he sent me
to the island Fortress of Dragonstone
along with my mother Queen Raa who was
great with
child but as my father my king Aries
Targaryen prepared to defend his throne
to The Bitter
End little did he know of the horrors
and betrayals that awaited him and our
family